alcune opere d'arte vivono dentro di noi
Da quando per la prima volta da bambini
le abbiamo incontrate su un libro di
scuola una di queste opere è certamente
il discobolo una straordinaria
potentissima immagine di un gesto
Atletico
E allora quando andiamo al Museo
nazionale romano nel cuore di Roma una
delle prime cose che facciamo è proprio
andare nella sala del discobolo a
cercare quest'opera E quando ci
arriviamo Certo lo troviamo ma con una
sorpresa ne troviamo due due statue un
po' diverse hanno qualche differenza
stilistica una delle due alla testa
l'altra no ma è indubbio che si tratti
di due versioni della medesima
composizione
a quel punto ci vengono in aiuto le
didascalie che ci spiegano che si tratta
di due versioni di due repliche di una
medesima opera due repliche realizzate
in marmo
in età imperiale romana nei primi secoli
dopo Cristo di un'originale creato in
bronzo intorno al 450 avanti Cristo
secoli prima da un maestro greco di nome
Mirone ci domandiamo subito allora E
dov'è questa statua celebre questo
discobolo di Mirone tanto famoso ma il
discobolo di Mirone è solo un'ombra un
fantasma non rimane nulla neanche un
frammento di quest'opera di quest'opera
restano solo poche parole di alcuni
scrittori greci e latini che menzionano
il maestro che la realizzata l'aspetto
dell'Opera alcuni dettagli menzionano un
atleta piegato nel gesto del disco con
la testa rivolta alla mano che regge lo
strumento quasi pronto a saltare in
avanti con il lancio e grazie a queste
poche parole gli archeologi sono
riusciti a riconoscere nelle due statue
al Museo nazionale romano e in alcune
Altre tecniche della stessa composizione
l'immagine della Statua perduta del
discobolo perduto insieme al discobolo
tanti altri prototipi di cui oggi non
rimane nulla e che gli archeologi usano
quotidianamente in qualche modo non come
documenti della loro epoca storica Ma
come strumenti per guardare oltre la
copia al di là della copia e riconoscere
le forme di qualcosa che non c'è più
un'originale perduto gli archeologi
hanno riconosciuto anche che la stessa
idea del creare in serie quindi di
rendere la produzione più rapida più
efficiente con sistemi seriali non è
un'invenzione Romana già la bronzistica
greca di età classica quindi quell'arte
che immaginiamo come sommamente
originale si avvaleva di modelli e di
bozzetti per creare in maniera più
rapida le singole parti di una statua da
assemblare
E allora se buona parte della scultura
Romana che affolla i nostri musei è
composta da copie e se la stessa idea
del creare copie della serialità non è
qualcosa di nuovo
c'è qualche elemento originale in questa
produzione c'è qualcosa di nuovo in
tutte queste repliche la mia idea è che
sì c'è qualcosa di nuovo e l'originalità
di queste di questi oggetti risiede
proprio nel loro essere delle repliche
nel loro essere parte di un gruppo che
le rende chiaramente riconoscibili per
essere riconoscibili Naturalmente devono
essere prodotte in alto numero in
maniera efficiente si sviluppano così
tecnologie che attraverso calchi in
gesso tratti dall'originale o altre
repliche permettono con sofisticati
sistemi di triangolazione di riportare
le misure del prototipo sul blocco di
marmo e diventa possibile sviluppare un
gusto tutto Romano non solo per l'uso di
repliche per l'allestimento di replica
in grandi edifici pubblici facciate
monumentali Nei parchi di ville ma anche
per l'accostamento una accanto all'altra
di versioni pressoché identiche di uno
stesso modello come sono i quattro
Satiri versanti che vedete in questa
immagine e che tutti e quattro
provengono assieme Dalla Villa imperiale
di Castel Gandolfo repliche di un
prototipo probabilmente
creato da un maestro greco di nome
prassitele nel IV secolo avanti Cristo
così numerose così riconoscibili le
repliche permettono di articolare
concetti Generali che possono essere
declinati in storie quelle sì davvero
individuali e del caso del dia dumeno
che in greco significa giovane che si
cinge la benda intorno alla testa e la
benda della Vittoria
è un atleta vincitore creato nel V
secolo avanti Cristo in bronzo da un
maestro greco di nome policleto
non abbiamo nulla della Statua originale
solo qualche parola di autori greci e
latini e una serie di copie come quelle
che vedete sulla slide a sinistra una
replica datata intorno al 100 avanti
Cristo e rinvenuta sull'isola di Delo al
centro una statua quasi identica ma
molto successiva databile alla fine del
primo secolo dopo Cristo e oggi al
Metropolitan Museum sono quasi identiche
diverse sono nel supporto che hanno
addossato alla gamba destra chiaramente
un'aggiunta del copista una statua in
bronzo non avrà avuto bisogno di un
sostegno nella parte inferiore del corpo
e al via dume No al giovane vittorioso
di policleto erano associati alcuni
concetti la bellezza La gioventù e
quell’idea tutta greca che alla
perfezione estetica la perfezione fisica
corrispondesse quella morale
e così immediatamente riconoscibile
carico di questi significati l'atleta
vittorioso di policleto diventa un
ritratto Perfetto un ritratto non
fisiognomico un ritratto simbolico il
ritratto di un uomo un Tito o un Tiberio
Ottavio Di adumeno che condivide il nome
con la statua stessa e al quale
quest'ara funeraria la cui memoria
questa area funeraria è dedicata
ma l'originalità delle copie a mio
parere si cela anche in un altro aspetto
cioè nell'uso sofisticato della materia
per articolare grazie alla
riconoscibilità del prototipo storie
sempre nuove e questo diventa chiaro Se
ci spostiamo dalla grande massa di stato
in marmo a oggetti creati in materiali
più rari e pregiati ad esempio da tutte
le statue di Venere o Afrodite la dea
dell'amore accovacciata al bagno
possiamo isolare una miniatura di circa
6 cm in cristallo di rocca che oggi si
trova al museo Getty di Malibu il
cristallo di rocca per i Romani era una
sorta di super ghiaccio
un'acqua solidificata da un evento di
estremo gelo E allora tenendo insieme la
nostra Venere di ghiaccio possiamo
domandarci se abbiamo tra le mani
davvero la dea che la tradizione vuole
nata dalla spuma del mare e possiamo
domandarci se il calore del nostro palmo
non possa innescare una reazione opposta
e cioè far sciogliere tra le nostre dita
il corpo della dea e restituirci una
impressione l'impressione di un'epifania
effimera e irripetibile
alla dimensione del tatto si lega anche
la scelta di realizzare in avorio è
l'immagine a destra una replica in
miniatura anche questa di 8 cm circa di
un tipo statuario di una statua che
conosciamo da numerose versioni in marmo
addirittura colossali la più celebre
delle quali è l'ercole Farnese del museo
archeologico di Napoli è una vera
montagna di marmo l'eroe Ercole stanco
si appoggia alla clava ed è stanco per
una ragione che si rivela se giriamo
intorno alla statua sul retro ha in mano
i pomi delle Esperidi per conquistare i
pomi delle Esperidi Eracle si è dovuto
sottoporre a una straordinaria fatica ha
sostituito Atlante e ha dovuto
addirittura sostenere la volta celeste
si capisce Quindi come mai Ercole il più
valoroso di tutti gli eroi sia così
stanco
la stanchezza l'incapacità di movimento
di Ercole lo trasferisce dal mondo
inarrivabile lontano degli Dei a quello
degli uomini e rende possibile
realizzarlo piccolo in avorio un
materiale che nella mente Antica è
associato all'idea di mollezza di
duttilità di
bellezza e associato saldamente alla
sfera erotica e alla sfera femminile è
il materiale del tatto e della bellezza
e se la pelle di Ercole è soffice E in
avorio sembra sciogliersi tra le nostre
mani tutt'altro effetto evoca la pelle
di Marsia Marsia colui che aveva usato
sfidare Addirittura il Dio Apollo in una
gara musicale uscendone naturalmente
sconfitto e condannato a una croce
supplizio Marsia era stato condannato a
essere scuoiato vivo
le statue di Marsia le numerose repliche
dell'immagine di Marsi a peso a un
albero mentre si compie la sua sorte
sono non di rado realizzate
impavonazzetto il pavonazzetto è questa
pietra solcata da profonde venature
rosse pur pure
è una pietra che viene cavata
nell'antica regione della Frigia
nell'attuale Turchia E questo è un primo
significato dell'uso di questa pietra
che può richiamare il luogo in cui
secondo la leggenda è ambientata la
storia di Marzia proprio la Frigia
Ma le allusioni vanno oltre e in qualche
modo Grazie all'aspetto di questa pietra
si istituisce una somiglianza un ricordo
un legame tra il gesto di chi sta
torturando Marzia
rimuovendo strati di pelle per scoprirne
le membra al gesto dello scultore che
per via di levare rimuove strati di
pietra scaglie di pietra fino a liberare
in qualche modo l'immagine già perfetta
contenuta all'interno del blocco di
marmo
E persino le repliche più numerose
quelle tante repliche in marmo bianco
che affollano i nostri musei riservano
alcune sorprese se le si guarda da
vicino se non ci si lascia intimidire
dalla loro identità di copie ad esempio
il di addumeno cioè il giovane che si
cinge il capo con la benda rinvenuto ad
Elo lo abbiamo visto nelle slide
precedenti
osservato da vicino ci dice qualcosa di
più è un atleta è un atleta vittorioso
si sta cingendo il capo ma i suoi piedi
il copista trasferendo l'immagine in
bronzo in un blocco di marmo dovuto
aggiungere un sostegno e questo sostegno
è confermato come un tronco nodoso su
cui è gettato un panno un drappo e al
quale è appesa una faretra che dentro
evidentemente doveva contenere delle
frecce
recenti analisi hanno mostrato che tutta
la statua l'intera superficie era
coperta di finissima foglia d'oro
E allora questa statua probabilmente
grazie alle aggiunte grazie ai
cambiamenti nella sua iconografia e
nella sua identità materiale cambia il
proprio significato e dall'immagine
generica di un atleta vincitore diventa
un atleta specifico Apollo il dio
arciere per eccellenza il dio nativo di
Delo e patrono di Delo il Dio che come
ci dice il poeta Callimaco appare
circondato dall'oro dalla materia solare
illuminando tutti i luoghi in cui si
manifesta e portando la luce dell'oro
nella sua Epifania
e se arriviamo e se torniamo dopo questo
viaggio tra le copie nella sala del
discobolo al Museo nazionale romano a
Roma e guardiamo più da vicino una delle
due statue che ci troviamo di fronte che
hanno sollecitato le nostre domande
lasciandoci stupiti di fronte a delle
copie anche in questo caso Notiamo un
dettaglio in più un dettaglio che di
solito non
su cui di solito non ci soffermiamo E
cioè
una delle due repliche quella senza
testa e senza braccio conserva sul
fianco destro i resti di un lungo e
robusto puntello che sosteneva la mano
con il disco
l'effetto della Statua l'immagine della
Statua per un osservatore antico doveva
essere su per giù quello che ho cercato
di ricostruire con quel disegno e allora
se guardiamo quel disegno possiamo
domandarci Cosa avrà visto L'Osservatore
antico
Avrà visto l'immagine di un atleta come
ci racconta Luciano che balza in avanti
dopo il lancio pronto al movimento
quello che gli archeologi hanno definito
parlando del discobolo un gran palpito
di volo o non vedeva forse qualcos'altro
Cioè un'immagine ferma bloccata
marmorizzata congelata in una trama di
supporti che rende evidente la sua
stessa identità il suo essere cioè una
replica in marmo di un originale in
bronzo possiamo domandarci se
L'Osservatore antico non sia stato
affascinato incuriosito proprio tra
questo rapporto tra un originale che non
c'è più e che forse a un certo punto non
c'era già più in antico e una replica
che si rende visibile e si manifesta
come tale
e quindi quando visitiamo uno dei tanti
musei
pieni di repliche pieni di statue in
marmo che scopriamo essere delle
didascalie non già Quelli originali che
abbiamo incontrato sui libri ma delle
repliche e scopriamo anche che quegli
originali non ci sono più Ecco dopo la
sorpresa dopo gli interrogativi
sull'identità di ciò che abbiamo di
fronte dopo gli interrogativi
sull'originale sulla sua identità
provenienza e caratteristiche Io credo
che la domanda che dobbiamo porci è cosa
hanno di nuovo e di originale da dirci
queste statue che si sono repliche
Grazie
[Applauso]